les amis je me suis infiltré dans les
locaux d'ubisoft et j'ai réussi à voler
walsh tox 2 ou alors c'est ubisoft qui
sponsorise cette vidéo je sais pas
oui on parle de marcus pas le gars qui
présente des émissions sur game one je
parle juste de se garer rogers
apparemment on peut surfer hâter les
choses sinon ça s'appellerait finalement
j'étais on peut par exemple déployer un
drone effrayer les gens avec ça marche
bien à jeter monde heureusement la fin
du game salut les filles vous êtes bien
moi je faisais pas c'est ma première
heure de jeu
ces attaques ont bien dit m toi pour moi
oui les boules et ce mec t'es morte tu
es morte
tu es morte voilà c'est une mauvaise
idée tient aux humains tôt iolo beach
c'est pas grave c'est par trois côtes
cassées pour une moto gratuite on dit
pas non en merde ça arrive c'est parti
salut les copains radiologique est ce
que je perds tes jeux piratés les choses
rené les gars je n'ai géante en
tout-terrain theolia j'avoue très bien
acheter ou pas les gars bordel
apparemment marcus et cascadeur à mi
temps pas mal du tout dégage ça dégage
un sacré oms marcus même quand il meurt
il a du style moto gp
je vais bien terrain à las vegas non la
moto l'action sociale n'aurait pas dû la
fierté voilà la [ __ ] arrêté comme déjà
de moto laisse moi te conduire
iolo là je sais pas mais là je suis un
pirate et toute la ville
je m'en bats les couilles en fait ce
qu'on peut faire c'est piratés quelqu'un
et faire passer pour je sais pas trop
quoi mais un gang sera mêlé le but
regardez ça va être terrible au caire la
fait passer pour un traître donc le gang
devrait pas tarder à sais pas encore je
me tire je me tiens je me tiens bon
est-il serait pas temps de faire une
petite mission vol de véhicule
expérimental du fbi et livre le à des
tchèques des deux sexes et
l'organisation de pirate informatique
dans laquelle marcus et
allez on y as été bon
quel cascadeur c'est marcus ok c'est
parti pour la mission il faut qu'on
localise le véhicule
il est des recettes gris aucun problème
attends je pense qu'il faut fuir les
caméras pour le voir ou et il a déjà il
ya une porte d'accord faut que je passe
par là du coup n'arrange pourra rentrer
là faut que je perde 5 pourquoi je pas
pirater sa a banni call alors on va y
aller en mode discret iolo beach j'ai
porté à 1 813 en direct mais les flics
arrivent aux quels acteurs se marc
husson oui ce véhicule là mon gars il
est là et si j'appelle un gang pour
[ __ ] les miguel vieille peut être pas
mal ça voilà allez un petit règlement de
courtage il vous faudrait que je passe
par cette grille là en fait ok ok c'est
au fer vale ce moment ce moment fons les
il faut bien avouer véhicules merde
c'est s'est refermée [ __ ] on module
souvent arrêté les comptes du gang là
ils vont bien devoir voilà pour sortir
parce que celle là c'est le meilleur
plan du monde
je suis une grosse merde en fait les
portails sont reliés à un [ __ ] de
cirque électrique faut que je trouve
social kuyt tournée qu'il faut que je
pète ce boîtier là quand je peux faire
pour péter hec on va rappeler des gangs
laporte va s'ouvrir à l'est de l'autre
côté mais non mais c'est un sketch ok
pour que les portes puisse ouvrir pour
les sauvegardes ce que j'ai appelé le
petit gang taille humaine mais tu peux
coton cailloux non vous m'aurez pas je
crois que parrot 20ma doré était plongé
dans leur acheter des drones alors par
on peut passer par là mais qu on va
sauter voilà on va à lyon le beach
hockey personne nous a vus hockey non
ils ont vu ils ont pu noter au lock on
peut y arriver
fazila tu leur clope oh mon dieu qu'est
ce qu'il fait je sais pas dire r2 d2
c'est bon ça marche et ça marchait du
coup là est ce que je pouvais cette [ __ ]
importe c'est vrai tu restes
voilà
mon dieu ouais nan a laissé bon allez
c'est moi qui agaçait voiture comme ça
le pire à coeur de tous les temps ok les
gars cette fois on va pas blaguer
d'accord bon je m'inquiète pas être là
mais sa coiffe et voilà une entrée
parfaite pour drones [ __ ]
ap
et bim est-ce que la porte s'ouvre
où est la voiture la voiture est juste
là les gars oui je dis oui à léa plus je
marque votre véhicule les gars m'a fait
graver plaisir on s'appelle je me faut
pas couper à droite là si on peut couper
à droite regardez hop raccourci beach et
voilà c'est pour vous les gars merci à
tous sans aucune difficulté
ce taux qui tombe au téléphone qui fait
chier tout le monde mais [ __ ] je
croise tous les jours dans le métro est
comme ça et je leur fais la même chose
qu'à toi c'est faux juge de chance de
ramon raccourci à la branche aime pas la
course est allé yoloff aussi ok y'a je
suis là sous la mémoire lit quand ils
s'arrêtent pour ça moi je veux un peu je
couds du rap us allaient olalalala
[ __ ] les gars on vient de réaliser un
rêve en enfer d'un compagnie de bus
fantastique voilà bah c'était marrant
dix minutes devait s'accompagner de bus
les gars je vous laisse au [ __ ] mais
que voici il est leur studio plus le
kéké ça dégage qui peuvent stopper je
viens de loire est vraiment un don de
faire les choses bien
une photo pas les garanties c'est le fit
à l'est ouais merci les gars allez viens
on sera tous les deux loin de ta copine
brouillard et a largué aller tout cas
les amis je propose de customiser
légèrement sa palette n'en sa tenue et
je suis garé à temps bon rien pu ces
mammouths ont coulé par des magasins
mais qu'est ce tu vas faire alors on va
se mettre en mode style ouais 496
dollars le t-shirt dollars en fait c'est
les billets que j'ai donné pour
l'acheter qu'ils ont collé dessus à ce
prix là ça le petit effet corps de
squeeze c'est très bien ok je suis
captain america au niveau des chaussures
et ben voilà c'est très bien ça s'arrête
on dirait qu'il est chiant dessus
mentalement comme ça donc je préfère
plutôt voilà le petit chat mais
regardez-moi ce style mais qui peut le
stopper
ah ça c'est juste pour prix du t-shirt
ça m'avait énervé et ben voila j -ja fin
de cette vidéo sur baulche dox 2g
stationna plus ces cas n'hésitez pas
mais la vidéo que d'habitude ça sort le
15 novembre prochain
j'aime bien faire des vidéos sur des
gros jeux comme ça parce que mine de
rien en fait jamais voilà donc ça permet
un petit peu de varier les plaisirs et
c'est cool de faire de tout du jeu indé
dupas jeu vidéo du blockbuster voilà ça
voilà j'ai envie de dire qu'est ce qui
se passe si tu veux que j'aille sont
celles fournies lors sms à sa mère dans
sûr je fais partie des dettes sac mon
propre à la tenue prochaine vidéo merci
d'avoir gardé portez vous bien
ciao les petits amis ses marques et ce
qu aurait dit ça mais pas celui du vote
jean kiffer gars mois de baisse